hallo freunde mein name ist luca und ich
hab hier bloß pickel bevor wir mit dem
video anfangen muss aufzeigen und zwar
habe ich bei sondern mein iphone kabel
hängt fest und zwar nicht im app store
sonnefeld app von agco punkt gefunden
habe das fünf minuten gespielt und was
kam dafür eine meldung von konrad
relations the witcher leaderboards zu
hause level ich habe das spiel besiegt
13 1897 das war mein ziel und ich habe
das spiel besiegt und das ist mein spiel
physik und ziel und wenn und jetzt wird
spiel fanden die man uns kennt starten
wir natürlich wieder mit einem extrem
kooperativen namen ich schicke euch alle
und werden natürlich dieses spiel mal
wieder von hinten hin aufmischen da
kommt die wilma der angeles ist das denn
ein fucking als diese verfolgst du mich
die ganze zeit der zenit der hätten
potro letzten stunde gedauert bis ihr
den ersten
das ist nicht wahr
dieses spiel das war es von videos
einfach nichts zu tun haben und einfach
bürger steigt saubermachen oder mein
gott also wir start ist mit einem viel
besseren namen zwei ich ja ich schicke
euch jetzt kann es nämlich ihn niemand
was was an haben hier das ist immer der
das ist das schwierigste dass man sich
am anfang ein bisschen hocharbeitet dass
man so ein bisschen was fressen kann und
dann hier der typ dafür gar keine namen
aber jetzt sehe ich dieses ding dreht
sich meine ich wenn man sich darin
befindet oder guckt es dreht sich da
jetzt ein bisschen wenn ich rausgehe ist
das wieder ganz still
okay wir unser plan ist natürlich
erstmal nichts gefressen zu werden das
heißt ich begebe mich hier schon wieder
ein ganzes
mal schauen ob sich jetzt noch einmal
drauf mich zu essen alter freunde das
noch nicht war als ob es einfach klappt
ich habe mich einfach ich gleich ddos
genannt und seitdem rührt mich überhaupt
keine an ich kann einfach hier meinen
ganzen shit fraser ich kann einfach
machen was ich möchte niemand du dich
nicht kennt aber nicht denken gegen die
rg da man nicht niemals geld aber ich
fress dich und dann und dann jetzt neun
geweckt sache ich spreche ist die dame
aus wo war das der club- aktion ok ok
ich muss nur noch hier ein bisschen was
fressen dann kann ich ihn ja ja ja komm
gib mir noch ein bisschen was zu fressen
dann kann ich ihn locker aufnehmen
kommen kom kom kom kom kom kom kom kom
kom kom kom kom kom kom kom kom kom
kleiner zwischenstand freunde wir leben
immer noch
vielleicht denken sie sich wirklich dass
ich die ddos mein ziel ist es einfach
nur wieder irgendwer ihn aufzufressen ja
ja ja ja ja ja sind wir schon in den top
links nein nein nein das ist nicht wahr
gang albani und pp ist darin aber nicht
gleich los
guck mal wie riesig wir sind alter das
ist doch nicht wieder aufgeteilt
das ist doch nicht war als ob das so
krass ist als ob wir jetzt so krass
riesig sind einfach das kann doch nicht
sein ich komme gerade überhaupt darauf
klar als ob ich war schon mal jemals so
groß durch den kann ich durch die erde
hat eine boxershort gesehen das ist doch
nicht wahr ich war so knapp davor in die
top zu kommen
auch schilder vorher niemand auf den
hohen plätzen war der rts habe ich mir
gedacht ich nämlich auch mal hört dann
könnt ihr eigentlich nichts passieren
ich glaube es gibt sogar so ein paar
coolen namen die einfach sonstig
spezielles design haben veröff ist ja
die erde ich glaube wenn die daumen es
dann so einen hund oder so bei belgium
bisher belgien bei port ich dich kriege
ich ja jamaika dichtet der liga kommt an
auto und extras
gespielt ablief das irgendwie das ist
doch nicht war als ob ich einfach direkt
vor der erde sport das ist das spiel
hast mich doch auch irgendwie oder story
meines lebens ich verfolge die ja ich
habe die liebe geld
oh mein gott und da kommt spanien direkt
in uns rein geflogen ich glaube ja den
arm und sorry was ich sagen wollte war
ich glaube das ist echt eine gute taktik
wenn du dich irgendwas aggressives nennt
so a [ __ ] you oder i gleich ddos dann
kann man schon ganz schön weit kommen
ich meine mit gleicht jedoch bin ich
auch schon relativ weit gekommen gerade
meine taktik jetzt gerade besteht
tatsächlich wirklich einfach daraus den
ganzen übrigen steht hier die die kacke
von den großen teilen zu fräsen ich
glaub ich hab snoop dogg gespottet
schaut mal da oben rechts der groß ich
glaube dass es nun ein schild als ob man
das ist doch nicht war als ob ich mich
da wieder durch gesplittet habe jetzt
kann ich wieder von vorne anfangen mit
dem scheiß eia komm mach mein leben
kaputt bei dicken scheiße ich von dir
das ist doch dass man doch direkt meine
couch hier eine letzte runde
eine verdammte letzte runde ich starte
rhein mit my last round dass ich will
einfach nicht das kann als ob da die
ich fresse euch alle das war zwar schon
weil der letzte runde aber ich will da
komm ich werde jetzt das video und ich
schenke mein leben an denen er mich als
erstes essen wird hier in der mitte wird
es sonnig sein wird es sonnig sein wird
es sein dass wir das wieder mal willst
du mich gar nicht fressen oder so wird
kann doch nicht sein oder
natürlich ganz alleine mitten in der
mitte und keiner will mich fressen ich
bin sogar in nagano soweit com mond komm
du kannst es packen ist mich kommen com
ja das war es mit diesem video audio
wenn es euch gefallen hat will ich will
wieso fokussiert diese face kam ich nie
seit dem ich lange haare habe ich würde
mich über eine bewertung freuen wenn ihr
noch mal ein teil sehen wollt